sometimes it's really hard to figure out
what we're supposed to title these shows
because we always have like hey this
here's the story today that matters most
and we have a really big story eric
adams he's uh probably going to win the
mayoral election in new york well the
results come in and he says hey
something's not right with these numbers
there's like a hundred thousand more
numbers now than there were on election
night and all of these mainstream
establishment liberal and leftist
journalists are going oh here we go the
pro cr pro cop eric adams is trumpian
and it turns out he was right and this i
guess the city admitted this huge error
where 135 000 test votes were still
included and they have to now redo the
whole count trump of course is coming
out puffing his chest being like no one
will ever know the results and uh well i
think we will but it's a really
fascinating story not so much that they
made this mistake i mean that's really
important too because if it wasn't
caught who knows would have happened but
how the media reacted to it so that'll
be fun the other crazy thing is this
this story really tripping me out a
judge in ohio has sentenced several men
to be vaccinated okay i
i get it we want everyone to get
vaccinated i get it but for a judge to
be like okay sir you've you improperly
handled a firearm so we're going to do
two years of probation and vaccination
it's like
shouldn't that be for a doctor to decide
not a judge so that's that's that's just
creepy weird government stuff
and uh just in the same vein there's a
funny story about joe biden confusing
the tuskegee airmen with the tuskegee
syphilis experiments and he like
insinuated the the heroic airmen were
actually the guys with syphilis which is
just like joe what are you doing and
then of course bill cosby was just
released from prison so we certainly got
a lot to talk about tonight and uh we're
hanging out some good people so actually
i don't want you to introduce yourself
you just you know inside of me yeah man
i'm uh ben joseph stewart i was on last
time talking about
the fourth turning
and
i'm a filmmaker i try to talk about
stuff that most people aren't talking
about but i try and put a awesome
soundtrack and sound design to it and
make it more artistic and poetic
and um
yeah man i got lost this morning and i
ended up around dc so here i am work
perfect
serendipity just works out i'm glad you
were guided by the magnetic currents
yeah i had a crazy experiment on
mushrooms one time where i was like
walking around i was lost and i was like
where am i you know i'm in manhattan
beach and then all of a sudden i was
right back where i started
i didn't intend to get back there but i
was guided something guided me or was it
coincidence
no there's no such thing it was the
mushrooms for sure
trust me i'm not an expert well i'm in
crossland i'm also not an expert
thanks and i'm here in the corner i am
intrigued by this retelling of the votes
in the new york city mayoral race
because eric adams is an
african-american retired cop and if this
were happening in georgia they would be
crying racism so hard so i'm really
curious what happens we'll see what
happens a lot of numbers i know before
we get started of course you always i
always say go to timcast.com become a
member
oh man the alpha version of the site is
sitting in my inbox and i have to check
it but we're here doing the show so this
is big because it means probably in the
next few days maybe next week the full
new version of the site will be up it's
gonna be fantastic we uh we have already
hired i think four people this past week
we've got writers we've got production
we've got our in-house camera person
they're moving out here it's gonna be a
blast our mysteries rider this is gonna
be amazing this this the article we have
so far you got to go to the site you got
to check it out but i know i know we'll
get it formatted better moving forward
but let me just tell you we got a bunch
of amazing news articles popping up
because we now have we've brought on an
additional reporter but also yesterday
we were hanging out with candace owens
in the members only section talking
about the mandela effect what a silly
conspiracy theory time travel oh how fun
and bill gates talking about population
management and controlling the
population of the planet which is a
legitimate ted talk we actually went
through the fact check and looked at his
ted talk you want to check that one out
um a lot of people are watching it so
that's a members podcast over at
teamcast.com and we're going to have
another very very serious i'm not going
to say we're going to talk about in the
bonus podcast but we're getting into
like the dark territory of
news i'll just put it that way let's put
it that way because i can't say too much
youtube will ban us but it's gonna get
it's gonna get fun and that'll be up
around 11. you'll see the title of it
anyway
let's talk about this news story out of
new york which is
it's not so much that uh here's the
story new york city will redo its first
round of ranked choice voting after
accidentally including 135 000 test
votes in official results okay okay
that's a very serious error right
i'm not so worried about this
um it is bad eric adams who was
protected wayne is a reason we say he
was a retired cop yeah he is all right
retired cop he's pro cop um he's
probably gonna win and he noticed this
what's crazy about this story is the
reaction from the mainstream press
i mean it is crazy if the dude didn't
catch this who knows what would have
happened would have been ridiculous but
the mainstream press
immediately comes out saying he was
acting like donald trump check this out
we got a few tweets here that highlight
a lot of this
glenn greenwald says this is really
amazing countless smug liberals
spend hours maligning and sneering at
eric adams as a trumpian fraud for
questioning the nyc election results
when those questions were completely
vindicated they slinked away michael
tracy said pundits at 5 30 p.m it's some
despicable donald trump-ish for eric
adams to question the veracity of these
election results
nyc board of elections at 10 30 pm turns
out we actually did add 135 000 fake
votes greenwald then goes on to say
media matters needless to say pushed the
same attacks on eric adams for
questioning what were clearly the
sketchy election results results which
were ultimately withdrawn as false
all right man look
we got some serious problems right now
with stuff like this
the media's in in instinctive reaction
is going to be tribalist the government
is always right
there's never any problems in the
elections trust everything on its first
go do do no fact checking
i don't i i'm less
how do i put this
the media is the problem is that is that
fair to say is that the easiest way to
put it yeah they're they're the story
spinners and they're definitely the ones
that put forward the stories that um
like you said this before they even knew
what was going on they already had their
story lined up you gotta wonder you
definitely gotta wonder
i'd say the media in general
what was what was that one i forget um
what they were like somebody lined up
the same narrative over and over and
over oh the gun thing
was you're talking about how you would
google search like
you would heard something like gun you
know x amount of gun deaths and then
you'd see all of these different news
outlets with the identical story
yeah
except they would change the name of the
city and the amount of gun deaths and
then they would all say you know so and
so advocates say that we must have more
gun control
you couldn't this is what's crazy about
this you wouldn't know about that
without the internet back in the day
you'd walk to your cafe or whatever
you'd pick up
the the the the milton township times
and it would have this crazy story about
gun deaths and why we need gun control
you'd be like wow that's crazy written
by someone you know
now today they do the same thing but we
go on google we see it it's all lined up
like tennessee milwaukee you know
detroit all saying the exact same thing
with the time news article time news
magazine where they have like a
different
uh cover depending on the country that
they're in because it's all about
manipulating the populace
they call it a b testing
so they'll they'll have uh uh
people actually point this out too they
they've you know depending on if you're
good if you're following some honest
people there'll be a cover for a
newspaper and it'll say something like
donald trump you know uh stands defiant
in the face of democrat onslaught and
that that will be a newspaper that
appears in a red state the same
newspaper with the exact same story will
reframe the whole thing saying democrats
condemn bigotry and corruption of donald
trump and it's the same exact story they
just changed the title because they know
different ones will sell
i would say that it's not the media
necessarily because this is media this
show and it's but there's like an
organization that owns a lot of media
structure like abc msnbc i mean i have
never really followed the trail too far
up the chain because a lot of times it
gets obfuscated you're uh you're right
you know media is archetypal like we
desire media and people congregate
around okay well we'll give you the news
like what was the first industrial
complex when they came out with the
printing press was that technically the
first i went through this at one point
to figure out what was the first the
second the third we're in the midst of
the fourth right now but i mean it
really launched by being able to get
news out faster quicker getting more
news out so that i mean like what is
news other than stories you should
believe but what is the underlying the
undertone is there's always a victim
that's you the reader you're always the
victim the freedom loving american
you're the victim and we'll tell you who
the the you know the bad guy is whose
head's on the chopping block today
because there's always a head on the
chopping block and it's always like look
at these terrible people
making your life so difficult and and if
you think about it like what would you
want in a family
you would want an example of what does
forgiveness look like how do we get
through this debacle you know how do we
not make it so where we always need to
bring the hammer down and sometimes you
need to bring the hammer down let's be
honest but humans uh maybe maybe we're a
bit like chickens we give ourselves a
little bit too much credit
like in in this story for instance it's
it's not like the journalists were
sitting behind closed doors all twirling
mustaches going
we're going to you know smear anyone who
dares impose
it seems like a genuine mistake this
city included these test votes or
whatever that seems like really bad
but they were all aligned with each
other and following that system that you
said who's the victim you're the victim
these are the bad guys they're the ones
who are in trouble so when eric adams
comes out and says hey i noticed this
problem they follow that that narrative
this guy is like trump he's trying to
pull a fast one on you and he's the bad
guy they didn't care to do any fact
checking right they didn't care to make
a single phone call to figure out what's
actually going on but i will mention
this is this is
legitimately true for all media
including ours so i i can do a video
where i did a video recent segment
couple days ago talking about how this
legislation in pennsylvania to ban
critical race theory was actually going
to be bad because it would prohibit
people from talking about
what uh it
it said you couldn't say things that
were racist or sexist
well if you said biological males tend
to outperform biological females in
football that would be determined sexist
and the legislation would ban that as
well it was like not the bill made no
sense but it didn't follow this formula
it was just like hey this is a bad idea
we should rethink these things people
are less interested in that they want to
know who's the bad guy making their
lives worse not everybody i think for
the most part this show is a lot of
critical thinkers who watch but we do
have like any other media outlet a lot
of people who are just like who's the
bad guy you know how are they screwing
with us and that tends to be the
narrative that everyone takes
it's almost like coffee it definitely
hits the amygdala
right the way the way that news arrives
at us there's an urgency there's always
an urgency and like in a sense i also
like that i listen to your show a lot
and i appreciate the
the immediacy of what's being talked
about and the urgency of it
what i do like about it is knowing
knowing you're independent and also
knowing that you bring on people that
legitimately have different opinions as
well you know so try to get a lot of the
leftists they're harder to get and some
of them are just i've i've seen some of
those interviews and you're right it's
difficult to actually get people to come
on to have those kinds of conversations
but i've seen the way you handle it and
i've seen the way you all handle it and
like you don't all completely agree now
you talk about other news there's this
but you know when was the last time
you've seen two anchors sitting side by
side like uh no that's actually not what
i think dude that would be awesome it
was called crossfire and jon stewart
went after tucker carlson and ragged on
him because he said it was bad that we
were debating on on public tv because it
was creating spectacle
and he was wrong
you actually had prime time television
where thought leaders were sitting there
debating ideas and so jon stewart comes
on and he's like you're a grown man with
a bow tie it's like john i'm a big fan
but like
we needed that space it's so hard to get
that back now it is we we have whenever
whenever i bring up it's hard to get
like hardcore leftists on the show i get
inundated with grifters
like people who have no intention of
actually having a real debate they just
want to pull sound bites they want to
lie and then there's that one famous uh
i'm not going to mention his name who
publicly says i will come on your show
i'm like
name the time and date we fly you out
here we'll cover all costs i really
appreciate it and he goes here's the
date i said great then he privately
messages me i'm not coming on your show
yeah the whole bit it was a bit wow yeah
it's really difficult now i'll be honest
there are some people on the right that
i'm also like these people are just
trying to you know come on here and drag
and they want to get attention and all
that stuff
but it's the exception not the rule
for a lot of these leftist youtubers
it's it's the rule not the exception and
i think that's true when you look at
someone like eric weinstein i mean this
guy's a pro he's
an elite wealthy teal capital
progressive saying something is wrong
with the democratic party and the
establishment and the media and here's
what i find really funny about this this
this whole media thing and these these
youtubers
like
following that that that system you you
mentioned how it's like you're the
victim here's the bad guy i'm like dude
they're the empire
they have control of the cultural
institutions they have the presidency
the house and the senate
i i can understand what people are like
you know from 2016-18 the republicans
had everything but they didn't have
colleges they didn't have cultural
institutions movies radio whatever or
even youtube youtube is dominated by
left you know left by the left and so
right now the right has like facebook
shares it's like dude you you're
literally on the side of darth vader
complaining about
the small
marginalized rural folk it feels like
the em it feels like the empire before
it became the empire in star wars when
it was still the republic and darth
vader had not yet donned the mask and uh
the emp the emperor still like wears
regular clothing and looks like a human
and and what what what changed what
caused that to become the empire and
star won what was it they they once once
he gained total control he eliminated
the jedi council then he was like we're
going to dissolve the the the the
republic and make it a new galactic
empire and they use the the trade
federation is like a false flag is that
what it was they were like yeah he was
manipulating the trade federation to
create a crisis that he would exploit
okay yeah so that's where we're at now
in history we've got well i don't know
about any grand it's probably just a
movie
yeah yeah yeah i mean i'm not gonna go
here sit here and assume that joe biden
is like secretly orchestrating taiwanese
uh aaron
i'm sorry chinese air invasions and
taiwanese defensive space or anything
like that
there's something going on with that too
because
it's either
super intentional the way they're making
joe biden look right now
or
and i i don't know what else i mean like
to say that he's coordinating anything
other than a couple neurons firing
together
you know it almost seems like they're
they're putting on an act to make him
seem worse than he is because like i
don't recall
i don't know you tell me
when the when the race was going on did
he seem this bad or did it seem like he
declined he wasn't he wasn't here
remember he kept putting a lid on
everything never shut up for any press
i got an idea for an animated short it's
joe biden standing at a podium and a
journalist asks him a softball question
and then he's like shaking and like
tensing up and sweating and it zooms in
on his brain and you see the last two
neurons like crawling to each other and
then they reach out and touch and
there's a spark and it goes
that's all he musters out that's it i
think he's not the emperor uh in this
metaphor but i think it's like someone
we don't know or actually i think there
isn't one and we're we're brainwashed i
think there's an enemy just like this
stupid news the emperor
remember he's two when the emperor's on
the ground and he's like please
in that moment right now yeah
you know what i like about this theme
that we're on though is um
if you know if things do go in a way
somewhat like that who was it that
actually brought balance
right
so i mean to me i've always been
thinking like you know i i research a
lot of really dark stuff i even have
people asking me like with the stuff
that you research and i'm not saying
dark as in like the worst of the worst i
really i just take a look at like
where's our data going what what is the
big push what's the big agenda going on
right now and people are like how do you
balance your nervous system when you're
reading this stuff every day and i'm
like i move i skate around i i
disassociate from my brain for a while
so i can hash it out on the subconscious
i can hash it out in different ways and
then i was thinking like
there's got to be really good people in
high places that just
their mouths are shut
and i'm not drawing a one-to-one
correlation with a darth vader saying
like no we're good guys don't worry
because there's some good people in high
places i still think there's an ominous
challenge that we're all facing right
now but i i just maybe it's just hope
but i really think there are some good
people in high places that are keeping
their mouths shut but when
i i don't know what s has to hit what
fan for them to really be like all right
this is this is when i actually use my
voice
you know this is when i actually take it
it's gonna be like a middle-aged man's
taco bell knight above one of those
dyson air blades that's like the level
of
oh that's the worst visual but but
like in star wars for some reason we're
talking about star wars
uh the empire had their reign and then
things did get better so long as there
are people in a resistance who are
fighting back now let's forget the the
the sequel films those were
trash i don't even consider them star
wars nah it's weird fan fiction but can
we can we talk about biden's mental
state to go back to this neurons firing
thing i've been wanting to talk about
his mental state for a while yes well
well now you get to
from uh this is from al.com biden
confuses tuskegee airmen with syphilis
study victims in explaining covet
vaccine reluctance what
this is the perfect storm of of biden's
brain
just breaking on tv because not only
were people like yo that's like really
racist for more than one reason he was
like saying that latinx people and
minorities
yeah yeah don't want to get vaccinated
because they're scared and he's like
remember the tuskegee airmen and it's
like oh dude
[Laughter]
okay okay okay let's slow down for a
minute the tuskegee airmen are heroes
there was didn't trump present an award
to one like a couple years ago oh yeah
recently he like stood up and then like
everyone was cheering for this guy
they're they're they're they're amazing
heroes
the tuskegee syphilis experiments were
horrifying acts where the government
basically told people they were being
treated for their disease but they were
just being watched die
they got like these these are people who
could have been treated the guy was like
yeah but we want to see what happens if
we don't treat them so we'll just keep
giving them placebos
that that
yeah joe biden joe biden ladies and
gentlemen
here's bob there's a story
check it out check this out let me let
me read a little bit
okay okay joe biden is drawing criticism
for comments he made that mixed up
tuskegee airmen a heroic group of
african-american world war ii pilots
with victims of an infamous alabama
syphilis study speaking on the
reluctance of some people to get coveted
19 bacte vaccines biden said it was
harder to get african-americans
initially vaccinated because it it used
to be that they experimented on them the
tuskegee airmen and others
i just i just want to say like all right
look i understand biden's not all with
it
my bigger concern is if remember when he
was doing the thing at the g7 where he
said libya instead of syria over and
over again
could you imagine if he's like sitting
there in front of putin and he's like
you want the sanctions lifted
you got to get out of libya and putin
goes
okay okay
and then like syria blows up
you know whatever that's the problem
with him not speaking properly now in
this instance it's more of a face palm
where he literally accused these heroic
world war two pilots of being syphilitic
men who are used by the government in an
experiment
it's gonna people are gonna think it's
true now too for their whole lives oh
yeah yep yep there are a lot of people
this is the crazy thing who they heard
him say it and it's it's like we're just
talking about the media yes that when
the when the when the nyc election thing
happens and this guy eric adams legit
like hey this looks wrong the media
attacks him like crazy how many people
heard biden say that and they're like
that's right the tuskegee airmen had
syphilis i think this is more like the
mandela effect we were talking about
last night because now he's interjected
this idea he skipped timelines it really
was the tuskegee airman
biden actually is the only one that
knows he's in the dimensional shift it's
gonna be like 30 years and someone's
going to be like on a podcast which is
like virtual reality or something
they're like don't you remember that
experiment with tuskegee airmen where
they were given syphilis and they're
like yeah i remember that it never
happened
dude
according to snopes.com it was actually
a cdc experiment
whoa
dude i remember though dude my great
grandfather served in the tuskegee
syphilis is an std right like these
these are so the study was like people
who got the std went to get treatment
and the government was like yeah we're
gonna give you free health care and then
didn't treat them and just let them
slowly die
like it's kind of dishon i'm not trying
to rag on people who contract illnesses
or anything like that but like
to look at this photo of these like
heroic world war two pilots and then joe
biden to accidentally say they all had
syphilis that's like a brutal thing to
say about these guys he owes their
family some reparations yeah
agree
reparations that's fair david e martin
in a talk he gave at the free and brave
conference gets into
it gets into the actual story with with
the right you know tuskegee experiment
so
well so i i have it this is interesting
i just pulled it from the cdc.gov
and what they say what they say about it
and uh we were just before the show i
had pulled up the original reporting
which they have here as well
they say in 1932 the u.s public health
service with the tuskegee institute
began a study to record the natural
history of syphilis they say the study
initially involved 600 black men 399
with syphilis 201 who did not have the
disease
participants informed consent was not
collected
researchers told the men they were being
treated for bad blood a local term to
describe several ailments including
syphilis anemia fatigue in exchange for
taking part in the study the men
received free medical exams free meals
and burial insurance
think about that they're like yeah we'll
we'll take care of you mm-hmm sure and
then like we'll pay for it when you die
they mentioned that in 1943 penicillin
was a treatment of choice for syphilis
becoming widely available but that but
the participants were not offered
treatment the us government knew they
could save the lives of these men but
the cdc and the u.s public health
service were like let's watch them die
and see what we can you know we'll write
it down
definitely garnered a lot of data i'm
sure
and you know david e martin who i was
just mentioning did say that the cdc and
i haven't actually gone to to verify
this but apparently started with
studying why malaria kills some people
and not others it's really like trying
to understand
plagues you know which which makes sense
for the the greater story of the cdc but
it is it is kind of interesting and
davide martin this was a talk where he
was talking about life insurance
companies and what we're experiencing
now as being a life insurance
illiquidity event
and i'll have to look at that well
people there's commercials like we will
buy your life insurance struggling
financially sell us your life insurance
reverse mortgages are you old and gonna
die we'll take your house from your
children yeah well he was saying 30-year
mortgages when that really started like
what 30-year cycles happened in nature
he was like nothing natural it was the
life expectancy of when a blue-collar
worker could buy a home to when he would
die
so you can pay off the bank pay off the
mortgage by the time that the bank can
foreclose on the house you know i mean
this this is pretty you know he's going
deep and he's very hyperbolic when he's
talking about these things but it what i
like about looking at these things and
then going and skating and hashing it
out in my mind
is not all of it is bunk like some of it
it makes you look deeper into history
and be like i i did not know that about
about the cdc
do you know what mortgage mortgage means
mortgage dead
dead like corpse death deal death deal
yeah that's the root word or or if you
look it up it says pledge so death
pledge yikes yeah like
why why why are we taking out death
pledges with banks right that's weird
i've even heard of the same thing with
like um
corp
corporations marine corps the way you
actually spell that corp yeah
well this was actually in one of my
films on grip that was all about it was
got into maritime admiralty law and
legalese how the name of a lot of these
things you it sounds like you're talking
english but you're actually not these
have alternative meanings like
well uh the latin is corporate meaning
combined in one body body yeah so maybe
maybe corp was the body not a dead body
not a dead body okay it'd be like mort
corp or something yeah
that's the name of my my death metal
band
dead bodies
mort court i like that you brought up
admiralty law i think something not a
lot of people know about is that there's
what is it civil law and admiralty law
there's there's a whole bunch and they
all seem to go back to ecclesiastical
law according to my my friend who did
this film
and it's an interesting thing if you are
in a certain form of law in court
according to my friend white walking
feather who robin the page family he
said you can pull it back to earlier
forms of law and he would always when he
was in court for not having a driver's
license and he gave up his birth
certificate and all those things he
would get pulled into court and he would
bring it back to ecclesiastical law
where they had to recognize him as flesh
and blood rather than
a legal fiction like before the social
security cards were invented like
they've kind of corporatized law or i
don't know how to describe it exactly
but like i'm fascinated with admiralty
law that's like the law of the sea they
say like you're birthed when you arrive
in a port and like you you come on to
the land as a fresh
you know
citizen or whatever your human resource
as well because that that number on the
back of your birth certificate uh is in
a human resource database
um
rather than like you know some kind of
medical database uh which makes sense
you know i i see a lot of people that
they they they draw
different things from all this and like
to me i feel like we've been moving into
this
managed you mentioned like when bill
gates was talking he said like was he
used the word management um popular
population management that word
we'll talk about more of that in the in
the after but
we can say this there's the conspiracy
theory is that bill gates
is like i'm going to kill all these
people yeah when he's actually saying i
want to make sure these people don't
exist and that's the acceptable
mainstream ted talk bill so bill there's
this article from reuters it's a fact
checker like bill gates did not say he
wanted to wipe out 50 of the population
what he said was we want to prevent
15 of population growth right
so it's interesting that
that's it's mainstream and acceptable to
be like if the people don't exist in the
first place we're good
can somebody verify real quick because i
mean i i watch a lot of media and
sometimes i keep an info in the back of
my head and i'm just like i don't know
but his parents bill gates parents
anyone familiar
planned parenthood i don't know okay
i don't want to dive right yeah i don't
want to dive too deep into that but the
whole idea about management is what i'm
talking about with like
where we're kind of headed with data
proliferation and data aggregators and
everything is data now your medical data
is being shared in ways that people are
starting to argue about but like where
we're heading through this entire
process that the world is going through
right now
is a lot more about management and
you'll hear people like alison mcdowell
who i recommend everybody go check out
wrenchingthegears.com allison mcdowell
is putting together
how
a lot of these dots connect and she's
saying a lot of it is poverty management
for the coming five six seven eight
years and beyond that's what bill gates
called is poverty management poverty
management and that includes reducing
population growth i want to mention this
just real quick like if you if you speak
french you know that mortgage means
death pledge
i don't i don't quite understand why we
call it that that it's not horrific yeah
i know like
a death pledge death pledge that's a
better name for a death metal band
or mort court
mort clark will be the first album
uh but let's let's let's let's jump from
biden's broken brain to
where we get into like the freaky and uh
this story like rightly freaked me out
i'm gonna start by saying something very
very simple
dr fauci is not your doctor and he
doesn't know what's right for you
because you could have some weird growth
on your butt i don't know your doctor's
got to tell you what that what that is
not fouchy
and joe rogan as well
these people are allowed to have their
opinions of course but you got to talk
to your own doctors i say to 51 million
times
because we have the story here columbus
judge is adding a new term to
defendant's probation get your covet
shot this is literally a judge
sentencing people to vaccination hmm
let me give you an example they say a
man named cameron stringer entered a
guilty plea for one charge of improperly
handling firearms in a motor vehicle for
which he was sentenced to two years of
probation
they called community control in ohio i
just want to point out is that it second
amendment lawsuit right there right yes
if somebody gets sentenced to probation
because they were handling firearms i'm
mishandling them then i think there may
be an advocacy group which could sue get
this taken up at the supreme court file
an appeal and maybe get it overturned on
the grounds of like you're allowed to
handle firearms whatever
now in this instance
i guess what happened was the gun wasn't
his so ohio was like not yours give it
back to the owner two years probation
and
stringer must submit to random drugs to
a random drug screening avoid further
legal trouble return a firearm in
question to its rightful owner and
obtain a covet 19 vaccine within 30 days
and provide proof to the to the
probation
i don't department it yeah why is a
judge telling people to get a medical
treatment this is the problem when you
have 50 million celebrities all being
like you should go get a specific could
you let me slow down imagine if you had
every celebrity being like you should
all be taking uh percocets like no no no
no no no like yes i understand why we
prescribe these painkillers to people
who really need them but celebrities
shouldn't be going on it's actually
against the law i'm pretty sure for them
to do ads that that they have to like
label them as ads when they advocate for
anything like a medical treatment or
whatever
yet in this instance it is widely
acceptable and in fact you can get
banned for even questioning it
the the doctor's got to be the one to
tell you man slight question if the
celebrities were like you should roll
around in the mud but then if they were
like you should roll around the mud
because it's good for your immune system
is that then considered health advice
where the first one is not
the issue is you're allowed to give all
the health advice in the world except on
this one issue that's the weirdest thing
now listen yeah there's a really
really
there right i know right right the judge
is not a doctor what happens if this guy
goes to the doctor and the doctor is
like uh you've got a lump on your butt
i'm recommending no for the vaccine
gotta overrule the court right right
right but what if he's like i don't care
i don't care what the doc he's like
he should be saying you should go to a
doctor and uh and request an evaluation
to see if you could get the vaccine and
if you can we would like you to get it
even that
is weird right you know like even saying
like i'm not gonna order you to get your
vaccine in 30 days but
i recommend like
what judge what what
jurisdiction everything is about
jurisdiction there
that's what i'm curious about where is
the jurisdiction to include that
what if the doctor was like
um
have you had your appendix removed and
the guy's like um no no your honor why
not i don't know well within 30 days
submit proof that you've had it removed
so i understand one's a more serious
medical procedure than the other but i'm
i'm super curious what is the precedent
for this we just got done talking about
the tuskegee
syphilis experiments like under what
circumstances should a governing body be
able to tell you you're going to get a
medical procedure you guys you guys are
going to love the next part of this this
is an article from dispatch.com this is
a usa today network website gary daniels
a lobbyist with the aclu expressed
concern about the practice thursday
comparing it to ohio judges who have
ordered defendants convicted of crimes
not to procreate
i'm staying away from
i ohio love you ohio but come on yeah mr
crossland you have been convicted of
rocking the gange uh for this you can
never have kids no babies you can't stop
me your honor
much love bro this dude this dude
apparently so like i actually have the
story this guy
um apparently had 11 kids and his human
his crime was not paying child support
are you joking that was the crime oh and
so
they were like you can't have any more
kids and he was like bs and he sued and
said you can't tell me i can't have kids
yeah and the supreme court was like you
can't tell someone they can't have kids
that's what i'm wondering with this
other thing is like my worry is like do
they have jurisdiction
is is there some weird wording in the
loophole
i'm i'm pretty sure they do a lot of
people since the vaccine thing started
have been saying like you can't mandate
medical treatments and you have no right
to my private records and i'm fairly
certain i could be wrong with this
that there's an exception in the
americans disabilities act for public
health requirements
and that does make sense i mean like
come on if there was a zombie apocalypse
you'd be right on board with whatever we
had to do to stop the zombie apocalypse
the issue now is actually i took that
back like it's politics man you'd be
surprised people i don't think people
know how to trust and and i know this is
like it might seem like a huge jump but
even if there was a zombie apocalypse
imagine the amount of people who would
be like i i don't trust what anyone
tells me i'm going to deal with this my
way
and i i kind of feel like that would be
a big issue like even if there were a
world event that could unite everybody i
don't think people know how to trust
enough right now especially not right
now i don't know if they ever did
you you're probably right about that
yeah um maybe small communities but this
like countries that are this big
definitely not but there is rule by fear
so i'd be willing to bet that if like a
zombie apocalypse happened in china they
would just gun everybody down and say
like look you know collateral damage if
we if we shoot everybody we'll save the
ten percent on you know non-zombie
people right or you have to move to ohio
that's that's even worse yeah
in ohio there was this man who um
uh
his house burnt down his cat died in the
house fire i forget his name i think it
was youngstown ohio but anyway he um
he had a pacemaker a smart pacemaker
and
afterwards the um the fire department
noticed that the fire looked like it was
set in several different locations of
the house so they went to the
manufacturer of his pacemaker to get the
data
they used that in court to show that he
was very active when the fires were set
so his pacemaker
testified against him in court holy crap
did you hear the story about uh there's
like a murder and then the police
subpoenaed amazon for i'm not going to
say the robot's name because we have one
uh subpoenaed like there's a recording
of this and everybody was like that's
not possible you have to tell it to
record and they were like oh no i
recorded everything
these these i heard more about that
apparently so is it domestic this is the
domestic abuse yeah something like that
and and it turned on and then the guy
was like did you call the sheriff and
then it called the sheriff when it heard
that
and then the sheriff listened in i don't
believe it this is what i heard yeah i
was it's interesting i can't get that
dumb thing to play the right song half
the time i'm trying to get it to play
some mountain john and it keeps putting
on some other weird modern hip-hop
garbage all over the world
yeah seriously it's it's got like 20. i
want to hear goodbye yellow brick road
it's got like 2050 technology in what
data they're trying to gather but when
you're trying to get your song to play
it's like circa 1922 technology
but but remember when they were when
police departments were using ring
cameras that people have on their front
doors they were hacking in and they had
like a deal with i think it was amazon
and these these entire police
departments could just tap on it
whenever they wanted to so i totally
believe that they used the little friend
over there to call the sheriff when
somebody mentioned that
it's all for our safety i hope you guys
know that i feel very right safety over
security security over freedom what does
charles eisenstein call it he said we
have been bowing at the altar of safety
for so long and somebody else put it in
a way he said
he said like
what we need to be doing is is
demonstrating living at all costs rather
than staying alive at all costs and it
really does seem like the way you manage
people is you make them believe that
death and destruction and bad things are
right around the corner unless
behavior modulation behavior you know
it's it's you have to modify your
behavior let me let me let me read you
the story from
sciencemag.org
a judge said police can search the dna
of one million americans without their
consent what's next there's also several
stories of states pushing back on police
subpoenaing ancestry data so people get
these kits from these you know these
these 23andme and ants
and then the cops are like let's hit
them up and get that data and so now
it's it's like a big legal battle and uh
this is an older story but uh very much
so where was that this is science
sciencemag.org it just says uh i can
read a little bit
uh
search warrant reported by the new york
times raises alarming possibility of
similar police searches of giant direct
consumer dna sites such as ancestry and
23andme that are now closed to everyone
except custom company customers
willingly submit saliva samples they so
they say a detective wanted to find
distant relatives of a serial
abuser hopefully that way in hopes of uh
in hopes their family trees could help
them hon and hone in
even though most of the 1.3 million
people who have shared their dna with
the site haven't agreed to such a search
so this is a
genealogy site called the ged match
not the first time it won't be the last
time no data misappropriation is
literally written into the fine print so
it can be shared in case of x y and z
and x y and z can be pulled out of any
hat and i just prints on your phone
interesting how many people have taken
their smartphone and given it all their
fingerprints for convenience and now
itunes or i'm sorry apple and google are
like when you have you read the terms on
this thing i'd be willing to bet it says
you give us access to your fingerprint
image to use and exploit as we see fit
because how else would it actually work
they need permission to use your
fingerprint then they have it and when
they get subpoenaed for your
fingerprints congratulations you
fingerprinted yeah totally totally and
you mentioned ancestry.com they were
just bought not too long ago 75 percent
of which bought by blackstone
[Laughter]
the other 25 percent is owned by china
i don't believe that check it out no way
ancestry.com last august
kind of what terrifies me that apple now
has my fingerprints you know
theoretically is that they could then
put my fingerprint somewhere
blackstone bought your dna come on man
look at this
yes
blackstone.com literally from their
website blackstone completes acquisition
of ancestry leading online family
history business for 4.7 billion yo they
bought your dna dude
and you know what the funny thing is
i'll tell you this they don't got my dna
they got my parents dna yeah that's
that's all they got both my parents dna
so they got they got some amalgamation
of yours though they don't know exactly
which ones made it through but they
might have enough they might know that
you are 97.3 likely to have a certain
gene marker or something like that
am i allowed to creepy am i am i allowed
uh what we were talking about earlier
with with the genetics yes am i allowed
to just
ask a question
i don't know
maybe we should save the really dark
stuff well it's not really dark it's
it's just a question about
testing
i would think so okay
well i mean like do you know who who
came up with the pcr test no gary mullis
yeah okay i won't even go super deep
into this but kerry mullis came up with
the pcr test he just died very recently
and
when the pcr test was starting to be
used to test he was like guys this isn't
what you use to test an active virus
inside the body
he's not around anymore to comment on
that um but
what pcr is really good for is is
rapidly replicating
dna rapidly replicating it pcr tests
like polymerase chain reaction and like
you know i i learned this by realizing
how you can teleport dna
via vibra via email you take
so basically and this was peter guyab he
was a russian scientist and then iona
and alan miller if anyone wants to check
that out
reversed this thing called the phantom
dna experiment i won't explain it now
but anyways um it was luke montagne you
might know that name yes okay so he
basically took dna infused it into water
kind of like cucumber infused water but
this dna infused water and then they
removed all dna particulate through a
filter then it's just infused with the
vibratory signature of the dna they took
that
they encoded that into an mp3 like file
emailed it from canada to italy i
believe it was then they took that
vibratory signature impregnated it into
distilled water and then from there they
needed one extra step to turn it back
into dna
and that was pcr i want i want to say
like when you break it down like that it
does kind of kind of sound crazy but it
just sounds like they found a way to
encode dna and transport it digitally
so so that was that story and the
question and here's the thing i'm not
making a statement here
i'm just kind of curious the guy who
created and got a nobel peace prize for
the the creation of the pcr test saying
this is not how you test for what you're
you're actively testing for
he could be wrong he might not have
known and it was all i got people who
say i don't think they're harvesting dna
and i i i am like so they're looking at
like a dna reaction to a virus with the
pcr test and then you think they're
using that data then and transmitting it
digitally elsewhere or that i don't
think it's that simple okay i don't
think it's that simple bro blackstone
just bought ancestry.com they don't need
to do any of that they got
that are on ancestry.com or 23 and me
because there's another one like 20 20
or via net 21 vianet or something like
that there's other dna there's the
23andme there's ancestry right and a lot
of them are actually bought by same
companies left with the same branding i
know 21 vianet i think that's what it's
called was also blackstone oh wow um
okay well i'll tell you this look look
look i i'm just gonna leave it at that
right we get to that wall where it's
like man we could speculate for 50
million years we have no idea other than
blackstone's a creepy company he was
buying up all the houses and they got a
d they got our dna
they managed 8.7 trillion dollars it
would be cool to send digitally send dna
to mars and then grow it on mars without
having to transport it that's kind of
interesting that's what catherine austin
fits in solari.com was saying with a
high-powered enough laser you could send
it off planet so here's the thing again
very speculative but i was wondering
like how would you send it off planet
and get through the aberrations get
fidelity through the aberrations of the
atmosphere just a long enough period of
time or send it or satellite or you send
it from the 30 meter telescope they're
trying to build on mauna kea that
for
real deep observation they use these
mirrors that react in real time to the
adjustments or to the aberrations in the
atmosphere to adjust the way it
distorted light back into a normal
signal so you could do the same in the
other direction
of dna and you're like what is this
aberration it sounds like what you're
saying is that they want to beam
they want to seed
other worlds with dna
i'm not gonna confirm nor deny but it
was darpa that said they wanted to start
putting bases on the moon and extracting
resources
how many how many how many exoplanets
have we found or or class m planets have
we found is that do they actually call
them class on planets i don't know i
watched i would love to know how many
we've found so um i think there's
actually a number because it's a big
deal when we find these these earth-like
planets or they call it what are they
called the goldilocks zone
what if they're just like we're going to
beam
the data of life onto these planets
through laser encoded whatever hit the
tide pool and then it hits it and
encodes certain dna and just makes it
happen just gets life started on these
planets
see like i
i don't get paid to stay within the
bounds of
you know i i like
theorizing beyond and then admitting i'm
just a filmmaker guys like i'm not
actually an investigative journalist i'm
a filmmaker um i love researching so all
the things that i'm saying
i mean like somebody somebody tomorrow
could come and say hey hey i i don't
think you get the nuances of this pcr
thing and i'll say thank you for
bringing that to my attention and that's
why i bring it up on shows like this and
i'll mention too the problem the reason
i say we hit that wall where it's like
we really don't know we can speculate
forever is the way conspiracy theories
work when they go bad is that you've got
to connect the dot's image that if you
it's you know 5 000 dots and when you
complete it it's a gorilla but if you
only see a tiny portion of it you could
connect the dots and you're like it's a
giraffe and you're like bro zoom out
there's way more you're missing and you
don't understand and we probably bump
into that all the time on this show as
does everybody else they they have
limited they only know as much as they
can know they're missing some
information so they connect dots that's
connect but they're missing context
totally totally and carol roth
excellent guest you just had on and
somebody i think you both were
mentioning like what do you think about
the great reset and davos and everything
and she was like i don't see a global
connection to it
and i was biting my tongue thinking i
have two words and one name for you
carol and that's allison mcdowell and if
i connect
carol to allison mcdowell's work because
here's the thing i think allison
mcdowell out of everyone she's been
actually putting maps together of where
the funding channels come what the
programs are what businesses
wrenchingthegears.com i'm just going to
say that i would love somebody to
actually break it down and show me how
what she's saying is not completely you
know on point because when you're saying
connect the dots
i also look at it it's like connect the
dots you can connect it in random ways
and it won't make an image it'll just
and then you can say well i don't know
if most of these dots even need to be
here on this page but once you see the
completed image put together correctly
then you see the need for every one of
those dots and i'm just going to say
those dots are big data big pharma all
the bigs right connected we don't see
them connected until you see them
connected and then it's hard to unsee
them i'm not saying
she's right and i'm not saying that i'm
right i'm just saying it's hard to unsee
it once you've seen it that way you ever
see those puzzles where you get you get
a grid you get a it's a graph it's just
like you know lines boxes looks like a
crossword puzzle but it's blank right
right and then you'll get another um a
key
that shows you it'll say a1 a2 a3 a4
then b1 b2 etc and in each little box is
a squiggly line
and then what you're supposed to do is
okay so b4 is this line i'll put it here
and then once you complete all of the
the instructions it forms a real picture
so each little box it's like you'll see
a line with a dot and you're like i have
no idea what that is and if you were to
draw 10 of them you'd be like i'm
looking at a bunch of weird lines and
weird little grid boxes
complete all of them and that's how you
draw a bigger picture right
so much like the connected dots thing
you may look at a small portion and see
a bunch of weird squiggly lines
and then if you zoom out and you're able
to incorporate all the rest of the
sudoku puzzle is it by the way and you
might even when you zoom in
see what you think like you said a
giraffe like you might see a completed
image that isn't the real completed
image that's intended or or a small
piece of it and the changes the context
right
like if you saw a picture of donald
trump on a surfboard with a massive wave
you'd be like whoa donald trump's
surfing i'm like this massive wave and
then you zoom out and then there's kim
jong-un painting a picture of donald
trump surfing on a massive wave and it
changes the context of everything
there's more of that picture can i just
say something real quick though
blackstone sounds like the name of a
villain in a video game dude it does i
brought this here because ben actually
on his uh last video on ben joseph
stewart on youtube talked about
blackstone and the scrying mirror which
was obsidian this is not real obsidian i
thought it was when i bought it this is
plastic i believe but obsidian is a
black stone that historically i believe
they used as a scrying mechanism yeah
i'm not sure what um you know the aztecs
used it for i think it was montezuma but
after montezuma was plundered a lot of
those
let's say montezuma's bling was sent
over to europe and
the adviser to the tudor dynasty
sir john d
very into magic and alchemy um
he used that scrying mirror and called
it a speculum
which is
uh if you look at the etymology
that that is at least in part where we
get speculation from because you would
speculate you know what you're seeing
um in in the scrying mirror right and
and then you look at the financial
markets and how the financial markets
are bigger than the actual economy it's
money
being produced from money it's not from
goods and services it's speculation it's
pure confidence if people believe
something has value someone all of a
sudden has currency
or can transfer it to currency totally
yeah and black stone came from black
rock larry fink split off i think in the
80s um
and split off from from black rock
there's also uh
graystone i think there's
what's funny is like larry we're talking
like lord of the rings like it's it's
strange but
there's a lot of those names because
even the son
of
blackstone's ceo or um black rock ceo
came up with a video production site
that was also like you know black
something they're very much so like
hitting on that kind of something about
black stones black rocks not really sure
let's do a movie yeah let's like let's
like script out because i'm just
imagining it's like it's like a rocky
terrain and there's a guy and he's got a
blaster and he's running and his shirts
ripped and he's like it's them it's
blackstone in a helicopter lands and a
bunch of guys jump out and they're like
stop resisting and it's the sci-fi
there's a dome for some reason and
you're like who are you we're black
water we're the the private military arm
black stone is the most ominous like
black rock black stone it's like dark
perry it's like but it's but it's so on
the nose that like the the protagonists
are like we've made it it's the fortress
of blackstone it's a giant you know
obsidian rock yeah yeah they're
basically how do we get in it's pure
obsidian or there's like there's a
there's like an uh a comet you know made
of obsidian or some other that's
probably nonsense every like 600 years
it orbit comes around
yeah
they said they said advanced troops to
earth to conquer it through economic
means
bro i mean look people they're buying up
houses like crazy
and it's very difficult for people to
buy
when they get free money from the fed
and
then we hear that they i mean what else
are they doing
oh blackstone yeah oh my goodness um
well you know
for one like right now buying up the
housing it's affordable housing here's
what i think that's about it's
affordable housing and single family
unit homes and this also comes on the
heels of again it's just something i
heard from a very reputable source
catherine austin fitz a lot of people
will just put her in
a kooky
category but she was under george bush
senior working in hud and she left she
was just trying to follow the trail like
where is these trillions of dollars
of missing federal budget going and she
traced it all the way up to more than 21
trillion dollars which was more than the
national debt and she was like this is a
different civilization so so anyway she
was saying that um a lot of what she
believes the riots of 2020 were
a lot of the destruction what's being
built up in its place is the smart grid
i have a sneaky suspicion that maybe
blackstone is taking these affordable
housing units for poverty management as
smart grid housing
so we we've talked about artificial
intelligence on the show before and the
misconceptions people have about it they
seem to think that if the ai takes over
like if we build an ai we'll get skynet
and a bunch of terminators will walk
around and be like you know or we'll get
ultron in order to bring peace to the
planet humans must be wiped out because
then we have peace no no it's not gonna
be anything like that what's gonna
happen is you're gonna in an ai managed
future you'll be you'll be sitting in
your house
you'll be watching tv when all of a
sudden your your your watch will go and
you'll look at it and it'll say jump
three times and you'll jump three times
and then i'll go bring you've earned
credits and you go yay and then it's
like you you go out you just you decide
to go for a run and then you're running
down the street and then and it goes
right turn thr turn left now to earn
three credits and you go okay you turn
left you you have no idea why you're
doing it or why you're being asked to do
it but when you zoom way out there's
something much bigger happening when you
jump three times you knocked loose like
a clog in a pipe that was jamming up a
line or something the ai knows it you
don't know it you have no idea why
you're doing what you're doing
that's the ai future so when we talk
about the smart grid and all that stuff
where all of these things are happening
where it's like they're buying up houses
and we here be chickens my friends
sitting in the coop having no idea
what's happening beyond these walls this
is probably nothing if it was really a
problem that we were talking about this
calling them out for buying up these
houses and shutting out the middle class
they wouldn't let us talk about it no no
you do have a moment in time to talk
about it before the the they can respond
i found a couple years usually it seems
like at least in 2006 and seven you
could call out
the big deal and and it took them they
were reeling they didn't understand the
masses are awakening how do we handle
this and it's like they're stunned for a
short period of time but i also agree i
don't think i think this is a front this
is this is what we're allowed to see
this is maintenance
we're allowed to out ourselves as well i
mean the thing is is like and this
doesn't mean anything really but like uh
my subscriber base on youtube was
growing steadily until i came on this
show and that's that's not an insult
that's basically like i think that's
when i got on a certain kind of radar
because it hasn't moved since then it
was growing steadily whatever i could
speculate all day honey trap of youtube
they're like we'll let tim pool grow so
we can bring on these people and then we
can pick them off and they can out
themselves very soviet you know you you
were saying about like the tokenization
that's what allison mcdowell is actually
saying a lot of this is moving towards
is tokenizing and so the economy might
be changing in a way where you are
you you get a token you are incentivized
to eat a certain way you are
incentivized to behave a certain way and
i mean like i won't get into where
pokemon go came from but it looks like a
pokemon go future where you're tokenized
for the right behavior exactly and
you're penalized for the not right
behavior and that's where the smart grid
affordable housing comes in because you
can be geofenced inside of your house
where none of your technology actually
works outside of it that's what
geofencing you know is already set up to
do
run from satellites does this sound
paranoid yes do i believe that we
shouldn't talk about it because it seems
paranoid no i think i think we should be
able to trust that people have a bs
meter and that people can do their own
research but like it's gotta at least be
mentioned right sounds weird right there
was a very great man who once said just
because you're paranoid don't mean
they're not after you right who is that
kurt cobain love it you know you my
perspective really changes when i get
chickens you know we we i love talking
about the chickens because they're
hilarious watching chickens is funny man
they have drama and like like there's we
introduced a new chicken and like this
drama and the pecking order and they're
like staring each other down but now
like the roosters dating the the yeah
we're going to do that it's going to be
the chicken city we're building a new
coop it's bigger and more space and
we've we're building the space out so we
can have the cameras hooked up right
into the
it's a long thing we're working the
avian show it's like the truman show but
check out i started thinking about this
because there are behaviors that i can't
communicate to chickens to stop doing
like taking a dump in their water so we
had someone say tim get a water nipple
system it's a bucket with little little
uh red spouts and when they peck it it
moves a little plug which makes water
come out solve the problem immediately
instead of instead of giving them water
to drink which they kept taking a dump
in i had to take it out and put intro to
something else now they have no idea our
conversation on this show happened the
chickens one day are sitting there
taking a dump where they stand and i
come in with a bucket full of water and
they're like okay and they still take
dumps ridiculous places they start
climbing on top of the roofs they can
dump so what do i do i got to put
something in the way to stop them from
doing it right it's really obvious when
you think about it we're not going to
tell the chickens what to do because
they don't speak english we're going to
put you know those pigeon things you
know like they don't want pigeons to
land places yeah they they make
they change the
environment change to get the outcome
they want from our behaviors people make
the mistake of thinking that you know
they're like bill gates oh we're gonna
we're gonna challenge him as if he's a
political rival bro he's a billionaire
he looks at you like a chicken
you are a chicken and and his his
mentality as he stated in his ted talk
was if we do these things we can change
the behavior of people and and
and and properly manage population he's
not looking at people like human beings
who want to have families who have hopes
and dreams he's looking at you like some
animal grazing around taking a dump
where you stand and he's thinking what
do i do to change their behavior to
create a better outcome that i think
would be the better out let's change the
system this is a lot of the ways i think
too because like i'm not into cult
worship i don't like a guy getting up
and be like i'll lead you there so i
want to build a better system that
allows us to flourish individually and
i'm sure he's thinking the same thing
but that can go horribly awry if you get
the
system the problem is every instance of
authoritarianism has gone bad throughout
history and we know it because no one
person no committee is smart enough to
manage billions of people and and these
massive economies so what invariably
happens is mass suffering but there's
there's a flip side of this and this is
what i asked alex jones i was like you
you talk about the the davos group and
all of these conspiracies what if
they're right though
what if left unchecked we will reach
mass population and end up you know just
constantly starved and fighting and
diseased we know what happens when deer
populations get out of control we know
what happens when hog populations go to
control that's why people get in
helicopters and fly around shooting hogs
they have a lot of fun doing it but if
there's too many hogs they destroy all
the plant life they attack people they
get diseased they starve and they die so
proper management of the population is a
good thing which brings us to the dark
dark questions of our own
humanity and whether or not
we get treated the same way in the
shower i was like thinking about weeds
weeds weed is just a plant that grows
really fast and basically takes over the
garden and strangles out all the other
things for nutrients like are humans
weeds have we done that to earth kind of
margaret singer actually used the
analogy of wheat she said we have to
weed the human garden and that's exactly
what planet that is so creepy the
problem is
when like if you had one chicken that
was killing the other chickens this
happens you have to remove it because
it's a dumb animal that doesn't
understand why what it's doing is bad
and not helping
humans arguing with other humans about
why they think
their ideology and population management
is the right plan it's the same thing
okay you know bill gates when he does
this ted talk he is not some like
you know uh intergalactic q-like figure
you know the star trek q who's
omnipotent and knows how to help and
guide humanity he's just another person
who's limited by the same news and
information we get is that why these
these elites are into the occult it's
because they're trying to get
information from like other
dimensions of intelligence so that
they're no longer chicken
maybe but that's just more evidence to
me that they're
not right that we we we don't know who
has all the answers and this you you
meant you you're talking about trust
like of a zombie apocalypse right why
should i trust that bill gates a guy who
sold software understands what it takes
to manage eight billion people or or you
know if he wants 500 million whatever
the georgia guidestones whatever he
actually
if if you actually take his ted talk for
what it is he's saying we don't want to
get to 9 million people so we need to
implement a bunch of poverty control
measures and then help everybody out he
does talk about making everyone's lives
better giving them better housing and
stuff like that i don't think i i
genuinely think he believes this stuff
when he says we want to improve the
lives of everybody the problem is we
have seen what happens when we run down
that yellow brick road from utopians
saying this is the way to get better
life and better living and then it turns
out it's a mass grave or a killing field
or something like that
why should i trust them it is pretty
interesting i mean like the the proper
management of the entire population i've
been thinking about that because
you know really it's such a
philosophical rabbit hole you can go
into like what is proper if you think
you've figured it out then what you
would want to do is just lay out the
plan and get people to comply no matter
what and that really seems like the
world today get people to comply you
know like you know offer them burgers
and fries get them to comply no matter
what they they did that in new york
i know
and you know so i mean the thing is is
um this this might seem unrelated but
like you know i have i have three kids
at home they're young my daughter on
elora might be watching hey
um so i was talking with this guy
charles eisenstein i was just on a trip
with him and we were just talking about
like you know getting you know when is
it time to get a babysitter and i said
you know like my
my wife she's so good with the kids that
sometimes that she
she like doesn't know when to allow
herself a vacation and to go and so
charles was like maybe say to her
instead of saying like babe you just
need to get it you need to do that
that's more of the like i'm telling you
what i know is right for you to do
maybe in like incentivize her in a way
by saying i trust
your intuition on when it's the right
time and you're calling her to step into
her higher
intelligence her higher potential and so
to me when i say like properly managing
people i don't know what to say about
the population thing i really don't but
what i what i do say is how do people
behave when they're told what to do i
know how my children behave and i'm not
going to make a one-to-one correlation
between humanity and my children but i
am saying like
i think there may be more proper ways so
i do believe bill gates isn't probably
sitting there with his fingers like you
know i just want people to rot and die
no i don't believe that i believe that a
lot of these people actually think like
man this world is going to be so great
they'll they'll come around even even
the people who don't like it they'll
come around
i kind of feel like maybe that's more
true but what is the more proper way to
get people to step into their potential
rather than oh well you know why are you
eating that way oh i was told to eat
this way well why are you exercising
right i was told you know why do you
live here i was told that's everything
though
you know we our whole worlds are based
off of information we've collected that
we trust
and once you get to a certain age and
your brain sort of solidifies and fully
develops you assert those things as true
to you and when people challenge those
you have a nervous breakdown this is why
people get really angry there's a lot of
people who aren't into politics and i'm
sure many people who are listening have
experienced this you'll be talking to
someone calmly and rationally and you'll
say look joe biden
fumbled and bumbled and then compared
the tuskegee airmen to
people with syphilis they'll start
getting really angry because what you're
doing is their brain has locked in place
these are the ideas i know to be true
why do i know them to be true because i
have survived this long and if i hold
these things thought my life to be true
my survival rate is better than if i
don't so when you go in and start
picking apart their world view you are
telling them what they're doing is wrong
and dangerous and they have to defend
themselves from that
they they have they have survived this
long they will not let you tear tear
those ideas apart so there's an
emotional mechanism
when people get angry they don't process
information the same way yeah so people
just go to an emotional state they get
mad they won't talk to you they shut
down a different part of the brain it's
more ancient and you know what you're
mentioning right there it takes me back
to all those beautiful on the african
safari um images where let's say a
couple lions are hunting down
you know one of the the smaller whatever
you know um gazelles
something like that that run those those
bigger maybe the water buffalo that run
in big herds so they're going after one
of the little ones and they feel safer
in the pack even though there's
three lions and literally let's say 150
of these huge massive beasts but they
will let one of their young die because
the rest of them are like we can we can
lose one we're safer in the numbers
most people that i know they're not
seeking truth that's why that's why they
have their brains seizing up is because
they're seeking safety they're not
seeking truth it makes me think how you
were saying about your wife and how to
inspire her to do to be able to handle
the kids it's like creating a leader as
opposed to telling her what to do and
creating a follower and that
there's a danger sociologically to
making everyone a leader because
especially like in the military if
everyone in the in the squad is trying
to lead the squad this nothing's going
to get done everyone's going to die um
so you have one leader everyone else
follows and sociologically i think
that's part of why psychedelics are
illegal because it makes you think for
yourself and make decisions for yourself
outside of external influence for the
most part uh more so than not it can in
the right setting but i see where you're
going with that but i mean it can also
be used by the cia in different ways
here's
here's the thing it was sprayed over
france and people were hospitalized in
it and it wasn't even
seen that lsd was sprayed over france
people thought that it was in the
drinking water they were dying or
something like that
there's a couple ideas in terms of
global control i want to mention
if there really is a very powerful
dominant group and youtube is playing
ball with them and seems like to a
certain degree youtube is at least
following some kind of establishment
narrative if the narrative is actually
controlled then you have to assume that
the success of this channel and
timcast.com is allowed to happen
or
i think the simple solution is there's
probably powerful elites with pop with
interests they align with other powerful
interests they use their weight to get
what they want at a disproportionate
level than most people so birds of a
feather flock together
but we're still
free and we're still challenged
challenging the system there's still a
resistance and
this this uh these ideals of say like
the davos group and the great reset or
groups like blackstone it may just be a
flash in the pen it may be that in this
generation some very wealthy people have
made some moves because wealthy people
make massive waves and they may not
succeed and then you know we move on and
i think it's more natural order like the
pharaohs of egypt i mean this goes way
back to the power control structure and
then they form corporations so that they
don't have to take personal
responsibility for the control and now
they can reap the benefits without
having uh suffering the bankruptcy
that's my personal feeling is that it's
always been like this
oh
yeah you know i mean like so
that's been my
my feeling as well is that this is a lot
older than just what we're hearing about
right now um
we probably shouldn't go into that right
now but i i do feel
i do feel like
it's obvious what you're saying like the
future is unwritten
and like we we still do have freedoms
like i know we i feel it i i sense it
when i go out to the store yes there's
something going on in the world right
now but like
it's not where most people think we are
but i mean you look at what's going on
in australia right now it's looking
pretty grim but do you have freedoms
the point is if if you are really to
believe that these powerful wealthy
interests look we know they exist i'm
not saying there's like a secret cabal
of people wearing red velvet robes
meeting underground somewhere and
chanting to each other or like you know
going to some like going to some grove
and worshiping a giant owl yeah like a
bohemian grove yeah i'm not saying
anything like that i've never been
invited to that party
man and they're they're rich people they
rich people have conferences together
they have meetings together they're
friends with each other naturally one
guy from one industry is going back
here's my plan the guy says oh that
works for me so these things exist but
like if we're gonna operate under the
assumption that they did have total
control like they could go to youtube
and say shut these channels down then is
it really freedom
when they're just like don't ban that
tim pool guy let let him keep doing his
thing it's good you know you know what
he did what i really like he had some
guy on this ben stewart guy who's had a
bunch of crazy stuff and then because
we're able to identify him we nuked his
channel you see what i mean
yeah i see what you're saying with the
freedoms thing and freedom is is uh not
not to get too philosophical here but
like it depends on when whether you're
talking about freedoms that are socially
agreed upon or the freedom i claim for
myself and i just behave upon
and for the most part like it it all
seems like it's it's it's being trampled
on but that also seems like history to
me i can see that we are in many ways
so much better off today than any other
time in history like i know a lot of
people that are like i would love to
just live
you know go back to nature and
i think that's such a romantic idea
until you realize what mosquitoes are
like when you live in nature and what
you got to wipe your butt with and what
water is like you got to worry about
amoebas and stuff you're boiling
everything like we love our conveniences
and this is where i'm at is i think
we're close to where we want to be
there's a lot of hiccups and i think
there there's always been this grab for
power and we've never been so close to
globalism we've never been so close to
globalism unless you you take a look at
what graham hancock and people are
saying about the ancient ancient past
but atlantis
right but i think you're even now is
even more
we're going through stuff today that is
like
really 10 15 years ago like only a
fraction of the population could even
like wrap their heads around
so like i think we're close i mean like
we all have phones i remember saying i'm
never getting a cell phone and guess how
long it took me to actually get a cell
phone two years
not even oh it's not even i was in the
band and i needed to to keep in contact
with them and then i was like i don't
ever need to get a smartphone i'm gonna
keep this nokia i'm gonna keep this flip
phone and it just it just angry birds
came out man and you watched your friend
play angry birds and you're like dude
how was i gonna know where the pokemon
were going dude without my smartphone
final fantasy on my cell phone and put
it on double speed so i beat the game in
twice as fast hey whenever somebody asks
me a question and i don't know it i pray
to google and divinely i get that all
you got to do is ask yeah yeah you ever
see that star trek episode where they go
to this planet
where
they're like the people are really dumb
don't know how to do anything because
their ancestors built this uh
supercomputer that did like took care of
their lives for them
and so then i i i'm maybe forgetting the
episode but basically what happens is
like they can't have kids anymore
something's happening so they try and
kidnap kids from the enterprise but
basically it's like what was brilliant
about the next generation is it showed
you the philosophical consequences of
certain ideologies technological
advancements and systems of government
in this instance you had people who were
managed by a computer within several
generations had no idea how to do
anything and just became completely
helpless
so
we're getting there as well i know yeah
i mean so so there's a story i love a
story i love
i read a long time ago about
a family on a beach when a black wolf
walked up on the beach and the family
panicked and ran into the water and
climbed on a rock you know you know 15
or 20 feet out and the wolf just paced
back and forth staring at him while the
dad the wife and the two kids were like
huddled together crying and terrified
and i think about that story and i'm
like maybe it's romanticizing the past
but i'd imagine if this was hundreds of
years ago the dad would have been
wearing thick leathers and had a sword
on him and he would have pulled out a
sword and said family get back and then
he would have like prepared or would
have had a spear or a shield or
something
now we walk around in like thin cotton
shirts
we're not prepared for fighting at all
asking where the police are yeah yeah
yeah yeah no i i totally agree and you
know i think history
i also look at it archetypally like what
is timeless like
as things advance like technology we are
giving up we're outsourcing a lot of our
thinking like you know people are saying
like we don't even know how to do math
in our heads we got calculators you know
what i'm okay with that i was never that
into math maybe some people want to know
math and guess what that the the
existence of a calculator doesn't mean
you can't learn math so there's certain
things i'm a i'm
happy to give up for the conveniences of
them because
i at least i've felt where my center is
and where i want my time and attention
to go so i'm i'm down with outsourcing
like i don't like
you know where gps is causing us to
forget how to navigate perhaps
perhaps but i don't feel like i've lost
how to navigate just because of gps but
i'll tell you what it has done i hopped
in my car this morning thinking oh man i
might be late for this for this
flight to get here and i just threw on
my gps it got me straight there told me
right when i would get there it told me
exactly how to get into the uh the
parking garage like it makes some things
easier it's not just the world is
getting worse and we're becoming super
dumb you have agency let's go back to
the chickens yes so the chickens are
taking a dump in all their water and
people on the show say tim buy the
nipple water thing and so i go on amazon
and i order it i have no idea what's
happening after that
the signal gets sent to a warehouse or
something some guy starts pulling
something out of a box the chickens have
no idea what's going on one day it just
shows up and their life has changed and
their water is now clean and they
probably don't even understand what
clean water means to be completely
honest
the reason i bring this up again is
imagine this you mentioned we're
forgetting how to do things oh the
calculator you know it's we forgot how
to do math and the gps we forget how to
navigate
we may be the chicken sitting there just
clueless and there may be i don't know
maybe there's some like rich billionaire
who's planning on integrating computers
into our brains with something he would
call what would be a good name for
something like like a link to your
neurons
yeah maybe there's a billionaire chicken
chip chicken chip
maybe while we're sitting here being
like look what this technology is doing
it's it's removing our ability to do
these things maybe elon musk is like
that chicken water thing already on its
way
to solve some problem that we may be
concerned about how technology is
affecting us and then neurolink happens
and you just said it how long did it
take you to get the cell phone yeah when
neural link comes out and then everyone
just gets it and they're going to be
like yo just uh you know link me the
information for the show and you're like
oh i don't got link it's like bro let me
let me just link in real quick and i'll
have him tell you and then you're like
i'll get a link hold on i'll try and get
it we're all going together and then
like there was actually an outer limits
about this where there were like wi-fi
nodes everywhere and people had it was
called the stream where they had instant
access to the network so they just knew
they if they needed to know something
they just would like think and then it
would be transmitted to them so imagine
neural link becomes ubiquitous and
you're like i'm not getting that neural
link thing and then you're trying to go
to the movies and your friends are like
dude i'm going to drive because i don't
want i want you getting lost with your
stupid gps like that's ridiculous i i
just know where to go right and then you
go okay fine dude whatever and then you
go to like you know neurolink mobile and
they're like it's a quick and painless
procedure we just you know click it
right into the back of your neck and
then boom you're linked up the other guy
be like bro i already got the the
upgrade i already saw the movie you
don't even i i see it before it even
comes out could you imagine like you've
seen every movie you guys want to see
fast fast and the furious 15 yeah
that was
he's like in the walker and then he like
throws it and fights the guy and the
guy's got a cane yeah well i i wonder
what people because um so terrell
mcsweeney i think it was she worked
under obama and anne biden i think it's
terrell mcsweeney it was like in 2000
2017 she was talking about the internet
of bodies and brain machine interfaces
and she was saying well the first thing
we really need to figure out is
innovation is way ahead of regulation
and what that means is what happens if
you have like your mojo vision which
gives you a heads up display in your eye
it's implanted in in your eye
and it goes defunct
who takes it out what if that company
folds who's liable to take that
technology out so there's a bunch of
that kind of stuff plus with the brain
machine interfaces
if you can because they're already
talking about what about people
with
tendencies i wonder if i can
even mention that word but like bad bad
tendencies can you suppress their
tendencies do you have the right to
suppress their tendencies do you have
the right to
introduce different
memories
you know and and these are things that
literally this woman was talking about
in front of a board saying we need to
figure out how to regulate it because
guess what it's already on its way
so like my my thoughts behind that are
you know like it's very interesting when
we're talking about technology i think
we talked about this last time because
there was this book um called what
technology wants and this guy was saying
it's very likely that no matter how many
times you rewind history and play it
again we'll always come up with
technology evolution will always produce
humans and humans will always produce
technology especially at a certain
population density so the interesting
thing is is like and i'm not going to
get you know spiritual or religious here
but for people who who believe that we
are all connected in some way shape or
form
where does god not exist
like technology you know like we we call
it blasphemous because we can't wrap our
heads around the fact that this could be
evolutionary this could be the you know
and i'm not saying where we're at and
tech now i'm gonna get so many people
telling me like like bro 5g and blah
blah blah i'm saying like no where
technology is at today is super
rudimentary i wouldn't implant anything
in my head i can't foresee that
mainly because the trust thing
i don't trust the the the reception the
the the vibrations the frequencies that
it uses i don't trust who would be on
the other side of it there's some trust
issues i'd need to get over but the
thing is is like at the end of the day
if it were benevolent if it were let's
just say hypothetically
would you
would you allow a technology that that
let's say could even be therapeutic to
you be not even implanted in you because
some people are saying bro you're not
going to need to implant it there are
technologies that can be a couple inches
away from your skull and still get the
same
neuronal um
uh agonist um or
transmit it it'll transmit and light up
the right parts of the brain you know my
my words are failing i like agonists did
you uh correct me if i'm wrong but
didn't the eye evolve on earth like four
different times independently six six
six i think it was six different times
in the cambrian era or something like
that independently independently and and
that's just one example in this book
they were talking about how like you
would still get no matter how many times
even on a different planet it would make
sense that you would have symmetrical
beings where the dna doesn't need to be
so robust that like just copy most of
the left side to the right side dna
doesn't have to be super jacked to be
able to do that on several different
continents um evolving separately there
were
similar things bipedal fingered you know
um creatures where their heads are you
know erect six five six feet above the
ground it makes sense to have that right
so this is really interesting when you
get into
religion
and simulation theory which i feel like
the the simplest form of simulation
theory is very rudimentary religion in
general the idea of a more advanced or
powerful entity or whatever creating
everything but when you talk about
technology as part of evolution i've
long thought about that like it's
inevitable and
it may literally just be that
uh let me let me slow down
life evolved through this this
competition this back and forth
evolution isn't linear right gazelle
evolved to run faster because lions are
fast and eat them and the lions have to
be faster and then eventually you get
different cats all of these things
happen until eventually
something emerges out of this adaptation
that bypasses the evolutionary process
intelligence and an immediate instant
knowledge based adaptation
before adaptation required generations
of life to emerge you had to have a baby
the baby was slightly different a bunch
of flies would get too hot and die but
the ones that survived could survive
hotter temperatures well then along came
humans with the ability to instantly
manipulate their environments with this
humans have basically told evolution
you're done because what happens when
the line shows up the humans invent the
spear and the lion can't get close
eventually humans invent guns and then
they own everything too hot humans
invent air conditioning and now they
survive longer in the summer too cold
they invent heaters now they survive
longer in the winter the technology was
the next level of evolution where a mind
the mind a mind evolved to understand
and manipulate the environment with the
right appendages for fine tuning fingers
fingernails all that stuff and now the
next step is going to be we create
artificial intelligence in life and
perhaps i was reading this i can't
remember who wrote this there are some
scientists who said their prediction for
life is that humans will create
artificial artificial intelligence that
self-replicates
and near the heat death of the universe
there will be supercomputers floating
around for billions of years collecting
loose electrons and after hundreds upon
hundreds of billions of years connect
them and replicate and keep going
yeah what's interesting is you actually
mentioned something that's in the book
what technology wants and it's how
how evolution happens in spurts and fits
and stuff like that but where the
similar things have evolved on different
continents
there's sometimes like something will
will jump ahead but there seems to be a
sequence in evolution and some things
will jump ahead but not far ahead in
evolution but once you get to humans the
interesting thing you mentioned about
how we change our environment you guys
know with plants like the phenotype is
what the environment does to the genes
what the environment pulls from the
genes
so when we change our environment we are
all automatically changing the
phenotypic expression of our genes which
we know turns epigenetic we know we pass
that down and the only difference is
with technology technology can radically
jump farther it doesn't have to follow
the same sequence of slow evolution you
have to go through this step to get to
that step to get to that step technology
can make leaps and bounds difference
uh you know different strides
discoveries yeah the discovery of the
charge electromagnetic magnetic spectrum
created a wave of new technologies the
discovery of petroleum within what
decades we made petrochemicals and
plastics and just changed everything
plastics really really were
revolutionary all of a sudden we could
make this moldable hard substance that
allowed us to make so much more than we
normally could did you see what george
carlin said about plastic no what do you
say what if the only reason why uh the
earth even created humans was to get
plastic didn't want the humans wanted
plastic yeah something had to make it
something you know and then and here's
our our demise and what's gonna be left
over all that plastic in the mariana
trench and you know you know what trips
me out is like we we have decoy ducks
you know we like you put a little wooden
duck in the pond totally and the ducks
come up to it and they're like what up
girl but they're talking a wooden block
what if like aliens have decoy humans
and we can't tell them apart
what if you know i mentioned the
chickens thing because i think it's a
really good analogy chickens they they
know me sort of i go in there and i do
stuff and they're like confused and
scared and always staring at me
but they have no concept of cars or
anything like this right to them it
doesn't exist as far as they're
concerned it's just weird nonsense we
see a bunch of weird nonsense all the
time we talk about the mysteries and the
paranormal imagine this
we're we're sitting here going like dude
i had a friend and like he once like
turned the corner and there was a large
shadow figure whoa and that's the same
as the chicken being like a giant thing
with like these things that were round
were like growling at me and it was like
the craziest thing it was this giant
rock with with gr growling
you know that's like us like we have no
idea we're talking about and for all we
know the aliens are looking at us like
dumb chickens going like giant giant
rock screams
yeah yeah what's funny is how much we
can all witness the same thing
but if you're not ready to see what
you're seeing your mind will fill in the
blanks differently than the person right
next to you you know that legend of like
when christopher columbus was coming to
the bahamas or the korean the natives
couldn't see the boats you ever hear
that mm-hmm so for those that aren't
familiar have you heard this yeah i've
heard this they so because their brains
had no concept of large vessels
they wouldn't even they would look off
the horizon and completely it was there
like they could physically see it but
their brains didn't process they ignored
the information and it wasn't until this
is how the legend goes one of the elders
noticed the wave patterns changing
looked up at where the wave pen was
coming from and said there's something
weird there and then told people look at
the weird thing and they're like what
what it's like it's right there like
oh there is a weird thing there
so i i i remember hearing about that
story and so i always whenever i'm
driving on road trips
um
in one since i'm with my friend and it's
a field we're like driving across a
great plane and there's a big cell phone
tower massive grey tower blinking lights
and the crazy antennas and i said look
what do you see what's what's right
there and my friend's like what are you
what are you pointing at i'm like what
do you see right ahead of us we're
coming up on it and they're like there's
nothing there what are you talking about
and i'm like dude people never think
about cell phone towers they don't know
what they are it's not relevant to them
it's out of sight out of mind so i was
like there is a tower right there
they're like what are you talking about
i'm like big gray tower blinking lights
and they're like oh yeah yeah yeah you
shouldn't see it at all because they're
like i don't know what i'm looking for i
don't know what you're talking about
part of what psychedelics just totally
changed me because when i would take
like psilocybin every outline of each
piece of thing i would look at and see
like i would notice all the things that
i'm familiar like familiarity bias i
that i gloss over that i'm desensitized
to in natural order but with these these
medicines or whatever you want to put
these chemicals i'm like very observant
of of the pieces and angles and shapes
of my surroundings they they say that
when the scientists like they put a
bunch of scientists in a room and they
were micro dosing on lsd or whatever
that they were able to see the things
they were normally overlooking
so it's it's like the idea i guess was
because our brains are rooted in this
routine in this pattern and we have
expectations it's hard for us to see
things that don't matter to us i
i think it's more of a case of survival
because jordan peterson talks about this
a little bit he's like if you notice
everything that's going on around you
all the time it's incredibly distracting
and you're going to lose your ability to
determine where there's possibly danger
coming from yeah there's there's there's
a filter i i was at aldous huxley who
said um it was the doors of perception
it blows the doors of perception wide
open
we
our nervous system would be
like on edge all the time if we noticed
everything we have these the raphael
nuclei in the in the back of the brain
and they light up when we detect novelty
something new
and
a lot of the times it's if
most of the times it's if you're ready
to see something and sometimes not you
know we we know that sometimes we do see
something that we're not ready for
um but the interesting thing
with psychedelics is
i think more the the auditory and the
things that aren't just visual we always
talk about what we see
but you ever listen to music on a
psychedelic or you feel like one hair
touching your face and it's it it's it's
it amplifies
what you're experiencing
and so like a lot of what i love about
the the more traditional ways of doing
it is they have a sentence setting that
empirically for thousands and thousands
of years they have it set up in this way
and it might seem really silly and dumb
to to blow tobacco smoke over somebody's
head and you know you know tap them on
the head over and over again with a uh
with a feather or something along those
lines while singing a song but you know
what like in those ceremonies those are
the most profound moments it's it's not
like you know
it's not you know just these these wild
kaleidoscopic things that you see it's
usually the insights you glean about
yourself and how the music got you there
how the smell of the tobacco got you
there so it's it's it's all contextual
as well and that's why i said when you
were saying like these psychedelics can
can open you up to a new world
i i think there's something about the
pharmaceuticalization
of psychedelics that they're even saying
can we take out the psychedelic
experience but still get the effects of
a boga like you know how a boga or
ibogaine is getting people off of opioid
addictions and stuff like that can we
just take out the psychedelic because
people that scares too many people and
they're all the the major like dennis
mckenna saying these are ordeal
medicines they heal people by what they
make you face on the inside we gotta go
to super chats but for completely no
reason i just want to mention two
paranormal experiences that i've had in
my life just because it's fun let's do
it the first was uh they both these both
happened when i was relatively young
when i was probably like 13 or 14. and i
remember one day i woke up in my bed
and there were
there were like black silhouette figures
walking past my door
and it was like three in the morning
and i remember seeing that and getting
freaked out it was like shadow people
people who experienced sleep paralysis
explain you know similar things i've had
that and then
i just decided to lay back and like
sleep on my side and keep my eyes closed
and just go back to sleep and ignore it
when it felt like
one of these figures walked up and stood
next to my bed and was just standing
there and i could hear like the
footsteps and feel like the presence
like
like you could just you just know and
i'm just sitting there like my eyes
closed i'm like i'm gonna ignore this
probably a really dumb thing to do
because like imagine if someone broke in
my house and i'm like i'm gonna pretend
like it's not happening so i don't know
maybe that's all it was maybe someone
broke my house in the middle of night
that's something something simple but
this the other experience i had when i
was about the same age i was laying in
my bed
and i woke up around two or three in the
morning clearly woke up and i was i
sleep on my side and i rolled over on my
left side and on the floor i saw what
looks like the reflect a very very
intense reflection of water
so you ever see like a pool and then
when light hits it there's like the
weird waves in the ceiling imagine that
imagine it like
two feet by two feet but intensely
bright it was this like pulsating and
that sent shivers down my spine i
panicked rolled over the other side and
just like started sweating profusely i'm
going back to bed i'm going back to bed
i don't know what that is i don't know
what i'm looking at i don't want to get
up i'm scared
yeah hmm creepy portal i don't know what
it is i saw infrared light one time when
i woke up i had my phone like right here
and i woke up and i saw the light going
in it looked like it was going into the
phone and i felt my brain like twist and
the light went in and it was gone i
didn't see it and i was like oh i wish i
could still like your mind's in another
place when you're sleeping let's jump to
super chat let's definitely do that i
just want to say your brain produces
drugs
dmt yes sorry
and five meow dmt dopamine
cannabinoids i mean uh pcp analog your
brain's got a lot of drugs i mean we're
all holding it internally in our brains
uh all right we're gonna go super chat
if you haven't already smash the like
button and go to timcast.com become a
member because we are gonna have a very
dark and serious bonus segment coming up
with a little music with a little music
that's right to lighten the mood before
we get into the scary series because you
may have noticed that the episode it's
like wait wait we'll save that one and
you might know where we're gonna go um
but youtube would nuke us in two seconds
so we'll keep this one for the members
and uh let's read some of these super
chats don't forget smash that like
button get your super chats in while you
can
name surname says if each of you could
have the powers of any video game
character who would it be i want to be
super hot guy
game character super powers man i mean i
i feel like you
you mentioned zelda and i know zelda
wasn't the guy but i think i would
choose zelda oh link you would want
zelda's like zelda s zelda's got powers
that's what i'd be yeah what's her power
zelda zelda
well
are you telling me i can't be a princess
okay hey hands off if you're zelda
zelda she turns into chic
it's like her alter ego and she can
throw needles
and then she has like the little
grappling hook and the like the string
bombs and stuff and zelda herself can
like teleport i think i would pick
i'm total zelda i picked nash from uh
lunar the silver star he's a lightning
mage although i do like healing powers
but i think i have commanding lightning
is pretty exciting
oh yeah oh i don't really play videos
pac-man
[Laughter]
i want to run from ghost and eat dots i
would eat berries
i'd say uh load runner i can dissolve
bricks in front of me and to my left or
right but not below me to trap
creatures that are chasing me which they
then climb out of the whole i'm kidding
that's a great question thank you for
that crash bandicoot you can spin really
fast and break bricks or something
yoshi mario can
can jump really high what what did they
say that uh eats mushrooms he can jump
21 feet when when you when you take the
size of mario on uh nintendo and then
calculate how high he jumps they like
mapped it out and said it's about 21
feet if if mario is the average height
you know if they said if he was like
five foot six or something interesting
he's jumping like 21 feet and he can
punch bricks and they explode
he shatters bricks with a fist throws
fire and then he puts on that cat suit
and plays around like a furry i like his
wardrobe he's pretty good his wardrobes
aren't he has cool friends too
all right jimmy quinto says who's ready
for this upcoming market crash in july i
mean i'm as ready as i can be i don't
know what how do you feel about that ben
man you know what um i was reading
something right before coming here
wondering whether it's true or not it
was a supposedly declassified document
about
a lockdown coming in the uk with
talking about specific years on what
shortages are coming in what years i
won't go any deeper than that but um
yeah i mean buy buy food learn how to
grow food maybe learn how to treat water
and get to know your neighbors do a
couple push-ups
there you go
splitting waves says dinosaur fossils
are creatures buried in noah's flood god
declared he would never again destroy
the world with water next time it will
be fire enter the ark through the door
that is jesus christ
i don't know about all that aren't there
aliens under denver international
airport i heard you guys this is the
word on the street yeah i mean that's a
really old conspiracy theory you know
it's fun and i never i didn't make
things i lived in boulder and i went to
dia i've never seen a dinosaur but
there's some weird stuff there those
murals are pretty interesting like
gigantic caverns under the surface of
earth we've only been like eight miles
deep and apparently like these ancient
aquifers that are now emptied like could
have microbial life much spore life it
could have animal life i mean we really
don't know
the mad machinist says biden is jar jar
binks convincing the republic to cede
power to the government by being hapless
harris is anakin pelosi is probably the
emperor
yeah
clef the misfit says let's finally get
this star wars analogy correct biden is
palpatine and kamala is darth vader
trump was mace windu but has been
defeated and order 66 has been ordered
luke skywalker is ron desantis actually
that that is a better analogy
order 66 they're like you know the war
on terrorists coming home
they're going to go after the militias
and all that so this guy's saying i
assume it's a guy i'm sorry um
that
kamala is going to bring balance to the
force oh i don't think so yeah but it
wasn't in a good way like bringing
balance to the force meant killing all
the jedi
this is true so there were like two left
i guess very disturbing all right
although you know one of the problems is
they say bring bounce to the force
because they're like two like so the
idea is like aha there were two sith so
then all the jedi white decks are like
obi-wan and you know yoda i guess except
now we learn in the extended universe
like so well not even extended it's like
canada it's canon ahsoka survived oh
disney upsetting the balance how odd
all right jonathan boggess says hey tim
i sent you a pitch earlier but it turned
into a resume so here's the pitch a
weekly d d game that explores dynamic
political cultural and socioeconomic
environments vibrant enough to elicit
questions and conversations from your
politically savvy audience done we will
hire the game master immediately send
your resumes to jobs at timcast.com
here's the idea you have one week to
come up with a a simple to play scenario
predetermined characters maybe do like
four maybe five characters you'll give
people their character sheets we need a
game master who knows politics who's a
big fan of stargate star trek and what's
people said mentioned far escape what
are some others
sci-fi
firefly i mean obviously star wars yeah
people who understand questions around
philosophy technology quantum physics
because then what we do is we have this
game master create scenarios and then
you create characters with certain
strengths and weaknesses have them play
out the scenario and see how it turns
out i like that i would love to play is
this a drinking game or yeah
it's gonna be it's gotta be fun and
silly and hilarious i like it where
someone's like the emperor and they're
like i'm executing the peasants give me
the drink i'm drinking
fortitude save and roll initiative it's
like natural 20 and everyone's been
wiped out game's over and i would love
to use uh dnd 3.5 but i'm open to 5.0
because it's easier it's easier to play
it's very very smooth but i love 3.5
it's a little more complicated
you think like in a week someone could
create a different scenario every week
that would be fun yeah yeah it's already
in there it's a good writer yeah and it
would explore it would explore like okay
in this scenario you're on a the death
star and you you're a janitor and the
rebels are coming to blow it up there's
this place what do you do
you save the death star because you're
like there's millions of janitors
there's like um
planescape i think was a dnd game where
you there's this realm where there's all
these portals that take you to other
dimensions of possibility so you could
every every episode could be through
another portal and then we could be in
another realm we could be in different
bodies i i imagine the conversation that
would come up around this i think that's
pretty
there need to be some like you know okay
too much talking not enough playing but
uh i had an idea for a video game and
i'll just give it away for free because
it's been decade but the idea was it's a
it's an open world game like gta or fall
or whatever and you play the game
normally monday through friday
collecting items trying to survive it's
like a normal world like gta you can get
arrested but on friday nights at 7 pm an
apocalypse happens and it's a random
apocalypse every week so what would
happen is you would develop say 13
scenarios then once the game is ready to
launch every friday you would do a
different scenario and then there would
be a repeat
so it'll be like randomized so imagine
this you're playing a game you collect a
bunch of bottles of water and food and
you get some guns then friday happens
and you're like 7 p.m everyone's sitting
there playing the game counting down and
it's like five four three two one the
moon explodes
dude
tsunamis happen fire storms so here's
the goal of the game next week you're
what you're counting down and all sudden
boom zombies start coming up from the
alleyways the idea is catching people
off guard and then after the scenario
ends on sunday who survived the weekend
because you you die you're out for the
weekend and then you come back on monday
and you start fresh and then what we do
is we count we analyze the data and say
when the zombies attacked 37.3 of people
ran out with no weapons start punching
zombies and most of them died you know
twelve point three percent hit in the
basement for the whole weekend
congratulations you survived and you
barely played the game
you can track that kind of stuff there's
also scenarios you can do where
you're counting down to seven pm and all
sudden boom your guy it says you've been
enlisted you are now a member of the
military a revolution is breaking out
half the people are chosen to be
revolutionaries half the people are
chosen to be the military look at your
friend right he's sitting right now yep
and then it's like
what do you do and then you use it's a
people would have no idea what's to come
and then we would just show people the
stats of like how people responded to
this apocalypse it's interesting because
you'll get into all the different kinds
of strategies because most people think
you know like oh man a big a big events
coming
let's prepare this way and this will
really tease out some of the nuances of
what certain kinds of preparation will
actually be good and which ones may not
because imagine this imagine like you
have no idea what's going to happen and
then a tsunami hits and everybody who is
just on the lower floors is just wiped
out ninety percent of people are wiped
out without even realizing it and
they're like dude and then they go in
spectator mode and they're watching like
they're watching streams of people
they're watching other people and there
was a dude who just decided to climb on
top of a building and he was chilling
and now he's on top of the building like
what do we do now but then let's say
someone climbs top of the building and
then a massive storm hits and then he
gets blown away like you have no idea
what's going to happen we should call
the game preparation
all right the comedian says snowden
called it the lassie effect where
politicians trying to tell us about nsa
spying but couldn't legally speak up
what's that boy timmy's in the well we
need to learn i blink morse code hmm
yeah writing in code that's something i
think da vinci did a lot of
because this stuff was kind of heretical
totally i don't think he did it through
eye blinks but he he definitely encoded
it he had an actual written code that he
would do totally yeah
i like i like a lot of those uh older
texts that you know we don't even know
if the author was really the author
oh yeah isn't it what's the the story of
the bible being written in code that tom
hanks movie that's gonna respond well
the davinci davinci code and there's
also um
oh man horowitz leonard horowitz breaks
down the code of the bible there's a few
people that break it down slightly
differently and that again shows you
apophenia can kick in at any time what's
that apophenia it's where you you see
patterns you can connect patterns that
aren't actually there
um that's that's the the overall
apophenia is like you can connect
patterns and they make perfect sense and
that's where a lot of i bet a lot of
conspiracy comes from not all but a lot
of people's conspiracy is like
when you break it down and there's no
evidence but like come on you know they
would do this in this scenario which is
really just uh we we got a couple
important super chats uh after all says
apple doesn't receive your fingerprint
or face id data it's all saved directly
on your phone apple has been doing a
really good job privacy wise
i find that surprising but all right
cerillo says on the fingerprint note
think of face id and that's and that's
use however i'd say it's in use i'd say
it started with real id compliance
stemming from the patriot act buying
tickets to orlando for my wife and i's
honeymoon in the terms you agree to a
biometric scan upon entry
there's this thing they have i'm not
going to mention the name of the company
where if you agree to a biometric scan
they say that they'll escort you into
the airport and i was all excited for
this i was like oh this is awesome
because i have tsa pre you know so when
you're flying it's like i just go to the
faster line and i gotta take up my shoes
or whatever and so i do this new thing
where it's like
they made it sound like they would just
walk me through the door and say haven't
i stayed cause they've checked my
fingerprints my face they've scanned
crazy background check
all they did was walk me to the tsa
pre-line i was like what am i paying for
and they were like well that's what we
do and i'm like i already have this so i
just canceled it interesting yeah that's
they walked me to the front of the tsa
pre-line with like three people in it to
be fair yeah
the whole the whole gathering biometric
data like it's definitely happening have
you guys heard of yoroi it's the light
wallet for cardano you know cardona oh
yeah definitely i have some yeah and i
mean there's a lot there's a lot good
with that but there's a lot about just
like harvesting the biometric data and
what cardano's doing over in africa but
maybe i'll save that for that's faster
for later yeah i wonder if there's any
way to avoid it or if it's just the
natural evolution of species
i don't think there is and i honestly
don't think that actively
what you call it like you know butting
heads against it trying to destroy it is
the way forward all right devin h says
hey tim there was a shooting in colorado
gunmen killed the cop a bystander shot
the gunman officers arriving killed the
bystander has received no mainstream
media this actually was yeah we are
change colorado it was a friend of luke
yep so uh luke knew him he and you know
he hit me up as soon as was happening
he's like i think this is what happened
and i was like bro and turns out
i mean look
a lot of people i see are blaming the
cops for this and i'm like it's it's a
tragedy
the dude was trying to stop a madman
the cop pulled up and saw a guy shooting
and he reports there was a shooting you
get a you're a cop and you report a man
just shot a cop and he rushed up and he
sees a guy standing there with a gun
shooting
and they're like i gotta stop him you
know what i mean yeah i mean really i i
wouldn't blame the cops in this
situation because like i mean it's so
easy to sit in your chair read a
computer and say what you would do in
that scenario yeah you know that this is
just it seems this is just one of those
very unfortunate events this guy was was
being a hero from the way that i saw you
know i saw luke's meme and it was it was
a nice one and this this guy really was
doing a heroic thing he put his neck out
there he paid the ultimate price and
probably saved lives
so
sky rowland says fresh and fit coming to
a tim cast near you
i've heard rumors
i've heard
grave367 is blackrock why does this
thorson want my house and dna is that he
pronounced it thorson who's thoracen
he's the uh uh that's the the um
uh the the the the dark uh dwarves in
world of warcraft
emperor thorson oh is it emperor that's
his name is emperor emperor thorson dark
dwarves from blow from black rocks yeah
rock rock downs black rock mountain i
never got there i my friends were all
level 60 by the time i was like 45 48. i
know i was like 10 levels behind so i
never got to
enjoy those realms from badlands on i
don't know where they're at now but i'm
pretty sure they're an allied race now
like you can play as them in warcraft oh
you're saying dark dwarf no i'm talking
oh okay i was like oh well correct me if
i'm wrong no no i'm pretty i'm pretty
sure you can i'm pretty sure he's in
hearthstone right he costs five he's a
five five and he makes all the cards in
your hand costs one less every turn he's
great yeah he's powerful and then his
wife when she her death rattle she
summons him i think
oh and then there's the grim patrons
whenever they take damage they become
another patron yeah yeah they're awesome
yep
great game all right let's see what we
got here blackrock beacon says with all
this talk about blackrock i feel the
need to say i'm not related in any way
to any other similarly named entity tim
thought the subverse named debacle was
bad at least the other guys weren't
suspected of being evil
oh
raymond chama says i'm being censored on
twitter raymond underscore thomas
probably
dagona says tim cast is allowed to exist
because it adds to the harmonizing
it's a good point i don't know i don't
know the harmony of nature
zoe mg this is awesome says tim is
openly controlled he's not allowed to
talk about fraud or medication for 2020
problems but i will say if you go to
timcast.com you want to see a
conversation with steve bannon it's
available there and if you want to see a
conversation with candace owens talking
about bill gates it's also available
there i think we're not long for this
youtube world but for the time being
we'll just make sure the platforms exist
where we can have the kind of
conversations we need to have we're
hiring more writers we're going to do
more shows we got the paranormal mystery
stuff on the way this is already so
awesome so we need the new website
format so it's easier to navigate but
then we're going to have a new
paranormal show i already have a name
idea for but i'm not going to say it
until we can claim all of the you know
proper credentials and everything but uh
it's gonna be fun the idea is we're
gonna have like a 10 to 15 minute like
actual episode where we'll have sound
effects and we'll have our our writers
will be doing voice over saying like you
know and then the guy did this it's
november 13th 1952 in alabama a giraffe
was spotted running across the street
and then you hear like hoofs clacking
and then after that like 10 minutes
storytelling we go into open
conversation and so it'll be like ian
chill and he'll be like dude this story
about the draft like how did you find
out about this and then we'll you know
open conversation so that we'll have
like members only stuff i'm so excited
for this it's gonna be so cool you're
doing a lot of cool stuff man
hopefully um there's like a story about
birds disappearing so you guys hear
about the racing pigeons disappearing no
they released nine thousand racing pages
yeah five thousand vanished and they
they release them and then they wait for
them to come home and see who wins and
they're like maybe a solar storm screw
with their magneto perception or
whatever but there's other stories
around the world right now of other
birds migratory birds like not showing
up
and so we got a mystery on our hands
like what's going on with these bird
disappearances and then you always have
these weird stories about like birds
falling from the sky just like in large
numbers
yeah like just like dying so we'll we'll
we'll have like a full and in-depth like
investigation into like these these
mysteries it's gonna be a lot of fun i'd
like to hear more about that because i
got my theories about the birds and i
would like to interview a bird i i
wonder if the cats have finally come up
with a plan and now they've they've done
it they've got the birds they're all
sitting there at the windows chattering
and then finally the plans come to
fruition and the birds are just getting
taken out one by one it's a mess it's
like order 66 for
the cats will have their revenge
music dc guy
says the star trek episode was people
who were ruled by the computer and they
did know but had a decree like the purge
they had to do
interesting
well this is crazy
nine tailed fox says tim i got drunk and
eating raspberries in the woods while
watching oh god did you get drunk from
the raspberries because be careful so i
just so why are you in the woods yeah
this you want to get the craziest thing
so i thought we had raspberries on the
property because like our neighbor was
like you know this guy who's not too far
away was like there are uh wild
raspberries all over here and so i
walked around and sure enough there's a
bunch of little red berries turns out
they're wine berries
they're not raspberries but they're
basically the same thing they taste very
similar they're delicious we also got
blackberries mulberries we got pawpaw
trees
we got pawpaw growing outside there's
but tim made some amazing was it goat
cheese with red wine berry and yeah it
was not red wine well they're red but it
was a goat cheese wine berry jalapeno
right from the property man and we have
these apples not the goats though the
goat cheese yeah the goats know we we
just like eating the dip with a sweet so
good i'm gonna put this on this it was
like an apple crumble from local apples
on the crab apple crumble it's allison's
crab apple crumble and we and then
allison and i made wild berry chicken we
took the wild berries we cooked them
down with some sugar and some lemon just
like like a jam and then we tossed a
little bit of it into like a garlic
garlic fried chicken
so it was amazing i'm so hungry right
now yeah dude
just i'm bringing that up just because
like
having your own food being out of a city
you know what's the craziest thing is
this app these apps we got like three
apple trees right next to the house just
right outside you don't gotta
you could eat for for weeks if you ate
nothing but apple you'd probably get
sick of them but there's just like
hundreds of them there's a bush next to
it with probably like three four hundred
blackberries on it
i'm like we gotta hire someone just to
like forage for us
but we're gonna do what you know we're
gonna do
i ordered a soft serve machine and we're
gonna take the wine berries and we're
going to mix them with vanilla and make
wine berry ice cream so you can just
like you know make a little like does it
wonder does it always mash it all
together for you in the machine
it'll turn it all up and everything and
then it'll come out and you'll have like
this nice berry ice cream it's going to
be so it's going gonna be so amazing
should look mulberries are legit too get
somebody to can some of them as well oh
that's good you know because a lot will
go to waste unless you know i mean i
would assume you could you could feed
some of that to the chickens but like
tim castle old-fashioned mulberry jam
and there was a cap would be a baby
yeah so paw paws they're like they taste
like avocado and mango combined
you can't buy those or mulberries
because they're too delicate to ship
but
you should i i wonder why people don't
like can you buy mulberry jam because
that's easy you just take it you cook it
down and we got we got pawpaw makes a
really good ointment as well really yeah
we got we have this we have this ma we
have a massive tree it's like 60 no
maybe was it like 40 feet tall you walk
underneath it you just shake a branch
and like 300 mulberries just fall into
it you know you put a blanket down or
something it's amazing
all right anyway
christian montague says tim please keep
up with the stargate references i've
been watching the series in
chronological order ever since you
mentioned it and i've been hooked much
love to lids and ian yeah somebody
mentioned that cause i was like star
trek star trek and they're like watch
stargate and i'm like okay and what a
good show this is sgg1 the show yeah i
saw the movie with uh geez who was the
movie was kind of whack yeah i loved it
i saw it in the 90s or whatever with
kurt russell and uh yeah yeah what's his
name from later he was on the office
oh um
amazing actor
yeah
actually one of my favorite actors the
main like scientist going through is the
guy from the killing zoe i think amazing
actor yeah that movie is weird but i
love being the idea of discovering a
portal and traveling i mean i don't know
why i'm obsessed with dimensional
traveling have you seen the star gate in
peru
i've heard about it it's like a little
notch cut out of a uh of a big rock this
is like ancient civilizations believed
it was a real stargate and they would
like sit would they go inside of it and
like their consciousness would be
teleported
i mean no one really knows there's a lot
of theories but i mean there's even cree
uh elders wilford buck saying that you
know the the star people came long ago
to tell our people how to travel the
cosmos and gave us maps of the cosmos
and we do that through our dna and
wormholes
so i mean like this is a cree you know
like up in canada north of the the great
lakes elder talking about this is what
their people have always known
so
maybe
did we mix up blackstone and blackrock
so black
rock
i believe was the first one oh no yeah
blackstone is buying entity and
blackstone is buying houses
somebody was mentioning they said it was
blackrock one came from the other yeah
but they're both active
yeah so like and they're both right next
to each other in new york like 1985 you
know black black rock and i think black
stone split from it larry fink went off
to start black stone and then blackstone
got far larger i think 619 billion
dollars is blackrock 8.7 trillion as
blacks you know i think it's the other
way around and i could be wrong about
that but i heard blackrock state street
and uh there's another one are the top
three investment firms on earth a black
rock
but black rock's the one buying the
homes right no no it's a black stone
yeah that's so confusing that is on
purpose look how similar those company
names are well they came from one
another blackstone bought ancestry and
blackstone is buying homes yeah one
company is black stone okay all right so
we got uh mr dub zaster says when
speaking with michael knowles you
mentioned rebuilding chicken city is
there a chance for a make chicken city
great again shirt i'd buy that for sure
oh yeah we want to do shirt designs
here's what i imagine we have seven
chickens well we have six chickens in a
rooster and i want to have like a like a
blue like a yellow circle with a blue
outline and then the chicken's head in
the middle and it'll say like team
vanessa and team margaret because then
we're just gonna put the cameras on and
have the chickens do their thing and
then you can buy the shirts for the
chicken that you like if you stare into
their eyes it's like if you ever stir in
a human's eyes and they look like that
you would think they were the deepest
psychopath bro we had four eggs today
but the oh
what am i even supposed to do with all
those eggs custard omelettes late night
omelette mulberry custard mulberry
custard
wine we got blackberries coming probably
in the next couple of days we're gonna
have hundreds of blackberries and we
probably freeze it if we need to yeah
yeah yeah we should make jams and stuff
in preserves and all that stuff i'm
stoked we should probably start actively
harvesting the the the apples and the
mulberries
because we it's it's nuts like you talk
to people around here and they complain
about mulberries you drive down the
street the road is just dyed purplish
black because there are trees that hang
over the road and it's just insane how
many berries there are but you could
walk right up you when they're when
they're ripe you just touch it and just
just put in your mouth you eat them
they're delicious
yeah almost like kiwi and we're talking
about food shortages coming isn't that
weird not for me though dude we got
chickens i know and now uh big news
roberto has started you know
you know what i'm saying
that's right i just called bob
bob that's right he started yelling
bobby you know he was he was yelling it
was funny at first he was going
and we would laugh at him and now he's
he's going through puberty and we're
like this guy you know we clear his
voice he yells randomly and like 15
times in a row and we're like bro we get
he's got to practice he's got tourette's
i heard he was practicing
chicken i heard like bok bok from my
side of the house earlier today my side
um but like was it turkeys wild turkeys
out there yeah yeah
probably turkeys
the wild turkeys are walking around all
the time oh nice but you may have just
heard homeboy yelling it was it was
weird it didn't sound like the right
area of the yard so i don't know i'm
sure yeah
i'm hoping it's turkeys
all right mandemar says
if you're into earth catastrophe cycle
rabbit hole a good view is the channel
suspicious observers i know it's
verboten to suggest guests but you know
whatever
powder pz says tim please make an app so
we can watch member content on roku
yes
we're working towards it a mobile app so
that you can listen to the members only
content with your phone us you know
their screen off
and uh roku it's called ott it's called
over the top
we're going as fast as we can all of
these things are in the pipeline the
first things first the new website i'll
tell you this man you know we had so
many people sign up it's an absurd
amount of members and so i went to these
companies and i was like is it possible
to just pay a ton of money to have this
stuff done in like a week and they were
like no
like no matt you you can't because
people are literally coding the more
cooked in the kitchen the more messy it
gets and then instead of actually
someone just going through and doing the
job you have people arguing over like
what what is this code what did you put
it bugging now i don't know what
happened we got to go back
there's only so much you can do and
always almost you know only as fast as
you can go but we're getting there so
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already you must smash the like button
we greatly appreciate it subscribe to
this channel and go to timcast.com
become a member because we are going to
have the dark
members only segment coming up should be
live around 11 or so
and uh it'll be available for members of
timcast.com you can follow us
at timcast irl on facebook and instagram
good news
facebook has determined that this show
is unoriginal and unworthy of being
monetized on their platform well sure
whatever we'll still leverage that
platform to get more people to the
website and you can follow me personally
at tim cast you want to shout anything
out ben
yeah just find me ben josephstewart.com
i got my own news show i do podcasts on
thursdays
i also do a deeper dive
section on stuff i can't talk about on
youtube
and um yeah the youtube channel is
youtube.com backslash by chance or fate
and you can find my news channels i just
talked about the uh the whole housing
thing
yeah and your ancient ancient
documentaries your documentaries from
like a decade ago are still
fascinatingly topical like esoteric
agenda kymatica on grip those three
particularly yeah there's a lot in
esoteric agenda that's coming to
fruition to today like what we're seeing
today we'll we'll get into that in the
members section oh yeah it's gonna be so
fun ben josephstewart.com
a lot of
a lot of people
will recognize the title about what
we're going to talk about the first
question i have but youtube doesn't
allow it so
same thing with bannon the first thing i
said to bannon in the
when we did the members only with bannon
i just immediately said the thing
youtube doesn't allow you to
to say bannon gave his response
so anyway we gotta do we gotta do hey
look it's it's it's pros and cons once
we have the website up we're gonna have
op-ed writers we're gonna have news
writers so even if we can't say it on
the show the website's gonna have a lot
of topics and talk about serious things
and it's going to be legit double fact
checked no no jokes like i'm the kind of
person who's going to go find like some
random doctor in wisconsin to say what i
want to hear about a medication we're
going to be like
you know this organization that
organization says this the fda says this
the cdc says this and we want people to
be personally responsible which one
would have as much information as
possible thank you tim call them into
their higher potential so they can make
their decision yeah don't look at me man
i don't want to get sued when you drink
soap or something you know i mean hey
and while you're at it not doing
everything healthy i mean um follow me
on the internet at ian crossland.net and
ian crossland on social media thanks and
you guys may also follow me on twitter
at sour patch lids
go over to timcast.com and we will see
you in the bonus segment coming up
shortly
you